beginning for the record what up Council
my name is Chad Kroger this is my
colleague JT we came to the city of
Miami beach with one purpose in mind
prove that partying on a yacht boosts as
much Stoke as we had hypothesized we
just gotta find someone to let us on
their boat yeah
Dave what's up man how's it going good
how are you my pleasure year 10 is
unbelievable I work hard on it every day
dude so we could really use a celebrity
endorsement for a public Yachts
initiative do you think Barstool would
be open to donating a yacht to the
public
what about the tax write-off
I'm here trying to buy my own this we're
not a charity no We Believe deep in our
cores that letting loose on a boat cures
depression so we would like to go one
step further with our proposal we not
only ask that the city provide public
Yachts to the people but also hot chicks
or hot dudes if you're a dude who's into
dudes
or hot chicks if you're a chick and
that's what's up man